how does it feel to work at tesla is
elon musk the twitter meme king really
that chill in real life or is it all
just a facade tesla's employees have
recently started being really vocal
about the working conditions at tesla
and spacex from calling elon musk a
genius that made them better workers to
claims of discrimination homophobia and
outright sexism tesla has it all let's
take a look at what elon's employees had
to say about him before we move on don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
press the bell icon done let's dive
right in
1.
he's smart
this probably goes without saying but
elon musk is pretty smart after all you
don't end up being the richest person on
the planet without some truly
revolutionary ideas a former manager at
tesla said he's highly intelligent he's
already 10 steps ahead of you you have
to think 10 times more audacious than he
does to be able to be successful the
manager also noted how elon will not
hesitate to put your ideas into action
if he likes them innovation is a big
plus at a company like tesla where the
success of the company is directly tied
to how they can change the world in fact
almost every company that elon musk had
founded has somehow been related to
changing some aspect of the world
2. employees are scared of them elon
musk might value his employees ideas and
opinions but there's just something
about him that scares employees two
former senior level employees said
people were scared to tell musk they
disagreed with him because of the
pressure that he puts on his entire
executive team his senior leadership
team even if they have the experience
they wouldn't dare speak up against him
this probably has something to do with
the fact that elon says he fires people
that repeatedly fail to come up with
innovation and since elon tries to be as
innovative as possible disagreeing
repeatedly with him is a straight ticket
to getting fired another manager at
tesla who had personally talked to elon
musk on calls multiple times said that
he doesn't believe elon musk knows his
name despite their personal interaction
he also mentioned that this was probably
a good thing since any employee whose
name got mentioned in a conference call
ended up getting fired not much later a
former manager at tesla said musk would
sometimes set unrealistic stretch
targets without a realistic plan in
order to achieve them it's a culture in
which if you don't have a solution to a
problem and you don't have that problem
resolved within a few days or a week or
two you're gone the former manager said
so it's better to keep your mouth shut
3. elon has been accused of dismissing
harassment
just this year tesla was blasted on
social media after the company lost a
lawsuit against it accusing it of racism
the company was ordered to pay 137
million dollars this came as a strong
blow to tesla who had always claimed to
be progressive and free from
discrimination elon musk also came under
fire after he emailed employees saying
in fairness if someone is mean to you
but sincerely apologizes it is important
to be thick-skinned and accept that
apology now you might be wondering why
this is a big deal well the thing is
workers from minorities have always
faced discrimination and being told to
just suck it up and have thick skin is
nothing short of abhorrent an african
employee cited racism and said things
said have made me feel like i was being
called the n-word i don't think people
of color should have to have thick skin
when it comes to racial issues in the
workplace as elon's email suggested
sexism and sexual harassment also goes
on openly a 55 year old materials
handler at tesla said i would never have
my daughter work there it's like a
nightclub attitude it's wrong the leads
and supervisors that see harassment they
don't want to make a big deal they all
say have a thick skin hey girl have a
thick skin tesla has denied all these
claims a spokesperson from the company
said tesla is absolutely against any
form of discrimination harassment or
unfair treatment of any kind elon
however has other plans it seems and he
himself was caught using discriminatory
language just this spring he sent two
emails to company staff and one to
investors in which he used the term
barnacles to describe low-wage
contracted employees the number of
third-party contracting companies that
we're using has really gotten out of
control so we're going to scrub the
barnacles on that front he said on the
investor call we've got barnacles on
barnacles so there's going to be a lot
of barnacle removal according to several
subcontracted employees this exacerbated
an already growing problem in the
company as managers that were already
discriminating employees were now
validated by the company ceo himself a
us army veteran working at tesla said
when the big alpha dog of the factory
uses that word to describe people it
allows other people in the factory to
start thinking about people like that
and acting that way the veteran had been
working at tesla via a subcontracted
company and compared what elon said to
the u.s military dehumanizing enemy
soldiers with racial and sexist slurs
when elon calls lower paid workers
barnacles then you have managers saying
get out of here barnacle i've heard that
word more in the last week than the rest
of my life after the lawsuit tesla has
decided to improve in this department
but no one really knows what the future
holds another side of elon musk that
employees revealed is his overly
optimistic dependent on social media one
four his dependence on social media
long-time tesla employees have revealed
that the only way to have elon musk
focus on something is to have it
highlighted on social media this is both
a good and bad thing as number one it
means that his customers are a priority
and he likes to stay connected with them
but at the same time number two he
focuses more on clout and public image
rather than what his team tells him a
former employee reported that what
ultimately triggers him to act and make
a decision is what he reads on social
media when you're in a business meeting
with him he will pivot the direction of
the organization literally overnight so
manufacturing could be a problem today
and as soon as it stops being reported
on social media as soon as it stops
being reported in the news then he'll
move on to whatever the news is claiming
the new problem is this does point
toward a lack of communication and trust
within the team and might also be the
reason why elon musk keeps announcing
overly optimistic goals which then turn
out to be unachievable he just doesn't
know
5. employees are embarrassed of elon
musk tesla employees have admitted that
they themselves are embarrassed when
elon musk lies to the public a worker at
tesla who had been there since 2017 said
i'm always really surprised how he keeps
giving numbers that we have never been
able to respect he would say we would
produce such and such a car by such a
date and we are never able to hit it for
me a responsible person should stick to
his word as a tesla employee i am really
ashamed when my ceo is lying to the
public don't get me wrong with all the
bad there is quite a lot of good about
elon musk as well
6. he's creative
when it comes to creativity you can
leave it to elon to take the cake he did
come up with a company that plans to
take humans to mars so that was expected
though mitchell stevens a former senior
manufacturing engineer who worked at
tesla from 2010 to 2012 said he thought
way outside the box stevens also
mentioned that the first time he met
musk the tesla ceo asked him and a group
of his co-workers what they saw when
they looked at a can of soda according
to stevens musk said you could see a
spaceship if you multiply the size of
the soda can
7. he's determined to do his best
elon has very high standards when it
comes to tesla and he's determined to
provide his customers with the absolute
best quality possible anytime he spots a
flaw he's going to have the entire thing
redone no matter the cost or reduction
in efficiency a manufacturing engineer
at tesla said musk sometimes took the
impulse to be perfect too far increasing
costs and reducing efficiency the
quality of the result is a testament to
musk's dedication to making the best
product possible other employees have
also mentioned how he pushes them to be
better a former senior level employee
said that he realized musk was right 90
percent of the time he disagreed with
him the employee also said i feel like
i'm 10 times smarter now than when i
first joined all in all what tesla
employees think of elon musk is a mixed
bag so we can't really form an opinion
on him from just a few statements and
well on that note we must end today's
video i hope you enjoyed watching it and
if you did be sure to leave a like and
subscribe for more with that take care
and i'll see you guys next time